-Stick around.
Come on back.
-♪ Snowball, snowball,
snowball fight! ♪
♪ Snowball, snowball,
-Yeah. That's the real deal.
That's my jam.
That's my jam right there.
Oh, my God.
An original.
Wow. Original there.
"Snowball Fight."
Not bad.
-We just learned it right now.
-Okay, okay. Good, good.
-That's the way The Roots play.
We did that once --
Springsteen was the best example
of that.
We had Springsteen
and Little Steven here.
And they were talking
and Bruce goes --
I had an old set list of his,
and he's like,
[ As Springsteen ]
"There's a song there --
Roots, Roots, you ever heard --
You know the song
'Wiggle Waggle,' right?
'Wiggle Waggle'?"
[ Normal voice ]
And Roots are like, "No.
We don't know the song
'Wiggle Waggle.'"
[ As Springsteen ] "Anyway,
it's the greatest song.
You'd love it.
Anyway, we played this song,
then we'd get
into 'Candy's Room.'"
[ Normal voice ]
Whatever. We talked.
And then I go, "Well, alright,
we'll be right back
with more of Bruce Springsteen
and Little Steven."
And The Roots played
"Wiggle Waggle."
And Bruce's face looked like
a kid on Christmas morning.
[ As Springsteen ] It was like,
"That's 'Wiggle Waggle'!"
That's 'Wiggle Waggle'!"
[ Mumbles ]
[ Normal voice ] I couldn't even
understand what he was saying.
[ As Springsteen ]
That's 'Wiggle Waggle'!"
[ Playing "Wiggle Waggle" ]
♪♪